salut à tous bienvenue sur l'émission
mini sport aujourd'hui on a notre invité
Laurence comment ça va Laurence
super avec Laurence on va travailler
avec les haltères qui vont nous
permettre de renforcer les bras et
d'avoir un meilleur confort au niveau
des mains éviter que les alternements
donc sur le mouvement des
jambes en avant tout le poids de corps
sur le talon donc le genou aligné à la
cheville on fléchit la jambe arrière et
pour ajouter les mouvements de bras on
va se fléchir les bras pour avoir un
meilleur gainage et renforcer l'avant du
bois donc voilà ce mouvement que vous
pouvez faire chez vous régulièrement 3 à
4 fois par semaine en série entre 15 à
20 répétitions en alternant la jambe
gauche et la jambe la prochaine fois on
verra d'autres mouvements merci beaucoup
pour votre attention par Laurence super
bonne journée à vous à bientôt